[Music]
think back to the first time when you
became aware of a deep injustice
do you remember what that was mine was
with grandpa lou
he was 80 years old had a history of
asthma and so when he woke up in the
middle of the night with chest pains
there was cause for concern a small
ambulance arrived and took him away to
the nearest hospital
there the on-staff nurse brought in the
only doctor who spoke mandarin
grandpaloo tried to explain what was
happening in his native language
but the doctor didn't see anything
urgent and left
grandpalu had no idea what was happening
in my community being born in the u.s
and speaking
native english opens doors i recognize
from a young age the obligation
that came with my fluency if i could
open doors with my english
it was also my job to hold the door open
for others
my mom always told me you are lucky you
don't have an accent you don't speak
with bad grammar
they will listen to you
and so as a kid i remember helping
people apply for visas
handling problems at the dmv and even
writing angry letters to their landlords
i've even pretended to deepen my voice
to call the bank as my father
but i was in college when grandpalou was
in the hospital only getting updates
from thousands of miles away
my mom and another family friend rushed
to the hospital to help grandpalou in
case there were any translation issues
now keep in mind neither my mom nor this
family friend are particularly
comfortable with english
but they were all grandpa lou had
during one of my mom's so-called
translation shifts
the family friend told her that they had
taken grandpa lou away to surgery
to remove his appendix my mom was
stunned
grandpa lou seemed to be recovering the
last time she was there
and appendicitis seemed unrelated to the
chest pains he was experiencing
nobody had any idea why the surgery was
necessary
or what was happening
it's unclear if the doctors even
understood that grandpalu had asthma
grandpa lou never recovered he never
left the hospital
he died within a week
back then none of us realized that
federal law requires
all patients to have access to
healthcare in their preferred language
back then none of us realized that
grampalu could have asked for an
interpreter
even though interpreters are sometimes
hard to find and sometimes lack the
right training
all we knew was that grandpa lou did not
speak english
and the american healthcare system
failed him
and let's remember english is not the
official language of the u.s
i'll repeat that the united states
legally
does not have an official language
and certain language barriers in
situations like health care
are considered civil rights violations
due to discrimination based on
national origin you see even back in
colonial times
our founding fathers recognized that the
united states is composed of a symphony
of voices
and to exclude any of them would be
undemocratic
and a threat to individual liberty
give me your tired your poor your
huddled masses yearning to breathe free
nowhere in the american dream does it
say
but leave your foreign tongues and heavy
accents at the door
according to the pew research center 67
million americans speak a language
other than english at home that's one in
five americans
we need an america that is language
inclusive
for too long non-native english speakers
have been othered
in my own asian american community i've
heard the internalized mantra
we're in their country we need to change
but for the millions of us who have made
this country our home
isn't this our country too
language is a core aspect of our
identity
yet the hegemony of the english language
has made life more difficult for
millions
across income level and educational
status
and let's remember this is not just an
immigration issue
the historical erasure of native
american languages is a tragedy
and yet another example of linguistic
injustice in the u.s
now if you're from a non-native
english-speaking household like me
you might have similar stories we've
never had the luxury
of not caring about linguistic justice
yet i've realized that many in this
nation including those in the business
world
don't really know what's going on
i've spent my career in healthcare and
impact investing
i met with countless founders who
excitedly pitch me their ideas
that will increase access and
inclusivity
yet very rarely if ever do i hear these
founders talk about
language inclusivity
in the realm of healthcare language
access has been shown to improve patient
satisfaction
increase use of preventative services
and lead to overall better health
outcomes
over the last nine months i've been
working on a startup idea to help bridge
the gap
in linguistic justice in healthcare and
to give family members like myself
better tools to assist their loved ones
with their healthcare journey
i've interviewed over 150 patients and
healthcare providers and when i talk to
doctors
many of them apologetically tell me that
they aren't able to spend as much time
with their non-native english-speaking
patients
others have gone so far as to admit that
language services at their hospitals are
poor
because they know this population isn't
litigious
others have admitted to taking care
instructions putting them in google
translate
and then sending their patients on their
way home
now machine translation holds enormous
potential
but it is nowhere good enough in
situations like healthcare
where complete understanding is required
despite the growth of digital health
tools during this pandemic
health inequity has worsened
take the coveted vaccine for example in
my home county
coveted vaccine registration forms are
only available in english and spanish
neither of which are my parents
preferred language
in la county one of the most diverse
areas in the u.s
their coveted vaccine information is
only available in translated forms
through google translate
all of my friends who have loved ones
who don't speak english
have been struggling to figure out how
to register their family for this
vaccine
i built a website to help bring together
this information
and to provide loved ones with a better
tool to share information with their
family in their preferred language
we saw the need for this in our own
families
and i want to help open doors for the
millions of families like mine
so i'll say it again we need an america
that is language inclusive
this problem is solvable
there are laws in place to support
language access
but it's often up to the private sector
to execute upon these policies
you see the business world has a key
role to play in linguistic justice
companies can all consider
multilingualism in the design of their
products and services
and bring in people from these
communities to build more trust
and connection of doing the bare minimum
companies can be at the forefront of
innovation that truly
broadens access
i want an america where my family
can easily access public health
information
i want an america where grandpa lou
could have understand exactly what was
happening when he was wheeled away to
surgery
i want an america where i can leave the
room
and know that my loved ones will get
treated exactly the same
we all need an america that is language
inclusive
so talk about this problem ask questions
about whether your company
considers language access in the design
of its products and services
develop and invest in solutions that
open doors
instead of ones that keep doors closed
and to the millions of american families
like mine
i hear you and i will open the door for
you
you